Profª. Tamar Gendler: Assim, o
tema da aula de hoje,
como vocês podem ver a partir do
título, é liberdade.
E o melhor modo de entender o
projeto em que estamos empenhados
hoje é contrastando as páginas
iniciais de A Theory of Justice
[Uma Teoria da Justiça], de
Rawls, com as de Anarchy,
State and Utopia [Anarquia,
Estado e Utopia], de Nozick.
Vocês se lembram que
quando líamos Rawls...
por alguma razão o controle remoto
não está funcionando...
é uma pena, mas vamos lá...
Vocês se lembram que quando
líamos Rawls, o texto começava
afirmando que a justiça era a 1ª
virtude das instituições sociais.
Ela desempenha o papel no que diz
respeito à legitimidade
de uma instituição onde a
verdade desempenha o papel
no que diz respeito à legitimidade
de um sistema de pensamento.
Rawls diz:
"cada pessoa tem uma
inviolabilidade baseada na
justiça
que nem mesmo o bem-estar da
sociedade pode sobrepujar".
E segue, numa passagem famosa:
"Por esta razão, a justiça nega que
a perda de liberdade de uns
dê direito a um maior benefício
dividido pelos outros".
Rawls tem o foco numa
inviolabilidade da humanidade
baseada numa noção de justiça.
Nozick também está preocupado com uma
espécie de inviolabilidade.
Mas em vez de ver o núcleo
dessa inviolabilidade
situado em alguma noção de justiça,
ele a vê numa noção de direitos.
Ele diz na abertura do prefácio,
na 1ª frase que vocês leram para hoje:
"Indivíduos têm direitos.
E há coisas que nenhuma pessoa
ou grupo podem fazer
com os indivíduos (sem lhes
violar os direitos)."
E ele continua, afirmando que
"um Estado mínimo,
limitado às funções restritas de
proteção contra a força,
o roubo, a fraude, de fiscalização
do cumprimento de contratos
e assim por diante justifica-se.
O Estado mais amplo
violará os direitos das pessoas."
Portanto, há algo
extraordinariamente
interessante
acontecendo nestas 2 obras.
Ambas estão preocupadas com a
questão fundamental
encontrada pela 1ª vez no
contexto de Hobbes:
como poderia ser
legítimo ter um estado?
Ambas estão preocupadas com a
estruturação do Estado,
de tal forma que ele não viole
o que é percebido como sendo a
imagem de algo inviolável.
Mas elas diferem profundamente
no tipo de Estado chamado de legítimo.
Talvez porque no cerne do
modelo de Rawls
encontra-se uma noção de
justiça, ao passo que no cerne
do modelo de Nozick está uma
noção de direitos.
Então, o que eu quero fazer na
aula de hoje é contrastar
alguns dos temas enfocados
na última aula,
no contexto de Uma Teoria da
Justiça de Rawls,
analisando um famoso capítulo
do trabalho de Robert Nozick:
Anarquia, Estado e Utopia.
Mesmo nas breves seleções
lidas destas 2 obras,
as diferenças devem ser
evidentes para vocês.
Elas foram escritas numa
diferença de apenas 3 anos.
Uma Teoria da Justiça foi
publicada em 1971.
Anarquia, Estado e Utopia em
1974, 3 anos depois.
Rawls e Nozick, na época,
tinham escritórios no final
do mesmo corredor.
Mas o trabalho de Rawls,
como se pode sentir, é parte de um
grande projeto filosófico.
É extraordinariamente reflexivo.
Rawls está na sua
meia-idade quando escreve.
E ele tem pensado sobre essas
questões por décadas.
O livro de Nozick é uma resposta
extraordinariamente perspicaz
para Rawls, além de ser uma formulação
positiva de um ponto de vista.
Mas não é um trabalho com a
seriedade de Uma Teoria da Justiça.
Foi escrito quando Nozick
era muito jovem.
Ele estava nos seus 30 e pouco anos.
E é importante saber que,
embora esses trabalhos sejam
normalmente emparelhados
em cursos de Filosofia (se vocês já
cursaram ou estão cursando
Fundamentos Morais da Política
ou Introdução à Teoria Política,
terão esses livros lado a lado)...
Uma Teoria da Justiça é 3
vezes mais influente,
olhando para o seu índice de citação,
se isso for uma medida, que
Anarquia, Estado e Utopia.
Portanto, as citações no Google
Scholar para Uma Teoria...
são de aproximadamente 30 mil
enquanto Anarquia...
conta com 10 mil.
São números
extraordinariamente altos em
Filosofia.
Outras obras de outros
domínios da Filosofia,
por exemplo Naming and
Necessity, de Kripke,
escrito mais ou menos na mesma época,
possui números de citação que
são a metade de Anarquia...,
aproximadamente 5 mil.
Então o que eu quero que vocês
levem para casa é a ideia
de que estas são 2 obras muito
influentes com consequências
muito além da filosofia
acadêmica, mas que diferem no tom.
Portanto, Anarquia, Estado e Utopia
é uma tentativa de defender
o Estado mínimo a partir de 2 tipos
diferentes de objeções.
Na 1ª parte do trabalho,
Nozick defende o Estado contra a
posição da anarquia.
Ele argumenta que um Estado
mínimo se justifica,
que não é uma violação dos
direitos das pessoas
ter uma aplicação básica das leis,
uma polícia e o tipo de coisas
fundamentais necessárias para
a estabilidade básica
em traspassar o estado de
natureza de Hobbes.
A 2ª parte do livro, a que
nos interessava,
defende o Estado mínimo contra uma
imagem mais maximalista.
E nessa parte, Nozick defende
os direitos das pessoas
à liberdade em 2 tipos de domínios.
O 1º é a defesa dos direitos
das pessoas em participar
de quase qualquer tipo de
contrato que elas gostariam.
Ele defende, por exemplo, o
direito das pessoas
em certas condições de pactuar com
a escravidão delas mesmas.
Ele defende, em outros contextos,
o direito de pactuar com uma
chantagem exequível.
Essa não é a parte do livro
dos trechos que lemos.
A parte do livro dos trechos que lemos,
e a que dedicaremos o restante da aula,
é a discussão de Nozick sobre a nossa
relação com a propriedade.
O que Nozick tenta fazer no Capítulo 7
de Anarquia... é articular uma noção
de justiça nas propriedades
– isto é, a justiça no que diz
respeito à propriedade –,
que fornece uma explicação baseada
nos princípios da relação
entre os 3 diferentes tipos de
preocupações que temos ao perguntar
se é legítimo uma pessoa possuir
um pedaço de propriedade.
A 1ª é a questão da
justiça de aquisição.
Em que condições
– quando eu adquirir algo...
digamos, um tomate –
a minha aquisição, tal qual a
minha apropriação do objeto,
está de acordo com as
condições da justiça?
E vamos falar sobre a opinião de Nozick
sobre a justiça de aquisição
em 1 minuto.
A 2ª questão que Nozick se preocupa
é a questão da justiça
de transferência.
Ele se preocupa com o seguinte:
se eu tenho um objeto
e quero transferir a posse
desse objeto para você,
em que condições se dá essa justiça de
preservação da transferência?
E, finalmente, Nozick está preocupado
com a questão da
retificação da injustiça.
Vamos supor que eu tenha algo
que você toma ilegitimamente de mim;
em que condições e como eu faço para
recuperar a posse do objeto?
O argumento de Nozick é
que podemos dizer
tudo o que tem de ser dito sobre a
justiça nas propriedades,
tudo o que tem de ser dito
sobre a distribuição da
propriedade numa sociedade
que não viola os direitos das pessoas,
apelando para uma definição
indutiva que é a seguinte:
Se uma pessoa adquire uma propriedade
em conformidade com o princípio de
justiça na aquisição,
a pessoa, P, tem o direito
à propriedade.
Então, se eu adquirir algo de uma
forma que é legítima,
seguindo as regras, a minha
apropriação desse objeto
está de acordo com as leis da justiça.
A 2ª cláusula é uma
cláusula de indução.
Se uma pessoa adquire uma propriedade,
em conformidade com o princípio da
justiça na transferência,
de alguém que tinha o
direito de ter esse objeto
– seja como resultado de
uma transferência
ou de uma aquisição inicial,
então a pessoa tem o direito
de ter tal objeto.
E, finalmente, uma
cláusula de fechamento.
Ninguém tem o direito a uma propriedade
que não seja pelas
aplicações repetidas de 1 e
2.
Aqueles de vocês que cursam Matemática
estão familiarizados com esse
tipo de definição.
Se eu quisesse dar uma
definição indutiva
dos números naturais, eu
poderia começar dizendo que
"1 é um membro do conjunto
dos números naturais".
Essa é a minha cláusula base.
E então eu acrescento:
"se alguma coisa é um membro do
conjunto dos números naturais,
então isso mais 1 é um membro
do conjunto dos números naturais".
E coloco algum tipo de
cláusula de fechamento
de tal forma que "os números
naturais", por exemplo,
"são todos e tão-somente aqueles
que satisfazem a 1ª e 2ª cláusulas".
Portanto, a imagem que
Nozick fornece aqui
é aquela que nos dá um certo
tipo de sistema fechado.
Vamos ver como ela funciona
num caso particular.
Nozick salienta que quando você
utiliza os princípios
articulados aqui, o que importa é o
processo, não o resultado.
Então vamos supor que eu
adquira um tomate.
Faz toda a diferença do mundo,
na visão de Nozick,
qual foi processo pelo qual eu
cheguei a possuir esse objeto.
Se, por exemplo, havia um pomar numa
outra rua, que não é meu,
onde um belo tomate caiu e eu peguei
esse tomate sem permissão,
a minha apropriação desse
tomate é ilegítima.
Mmm.
Mesmo se houver um processo
alternativo – um hipotético –
em que eu não me envolvi,
eu poderia ter chegado a ter
esse tomate legitimamente.
Se um ladrão toma a sua
propriedade, diz Nozick,
isso não legitima a posse dele
sobre a sua propriedade,
mesmo que você a tivesse dado
voluntariamente para ele.
Além disso, diz Nozick,
se eu adquirir algo
ilegitimamente e transferi-lo a
você
– mesmo por meios legítimos – o
status de ilegítimo é mantido.
Então, a imagem que Nozick
apresenta na sua discussão
das propriedades tem as
seguintes características:
A justiça na propriedade...
e isso será importante na sua
crítica sobre Rawls...
é histórica.
Depende do que realmente aconteceu.
Em especial, se algo é apropriado
como o resultado de uma
aquisição injusta,
isso produz uma propriedade injusta.
Se algo é apropriado como o
resultado de uma aquisição injusta
mais uma transferência justa,
isso ainda produz uma
propriedade injusta.
Se algo é apropriado como o
resultado de uma aquisição justa
e uma transferência injusta, isso
produz uma propriedade injusta.
E se algo é apropriado como o
resultado de uma aquisição injusta
e uma transferência injusta,
não é que essas 2 injustiças
cancelam uma à outra.
Em vez disso, temos, mais uma vez,
uma propriedade injusta.
Apenas sob 2 condições
é que as propriedades são
justas, na imagem de Nozick.
A 1ª é se é uma
aquisição justa direta.
E a 2ª é se há uma
aquisição justa seguida
por 1 ou mais transferências justas.
Até agora isso não deixa Nozick muito
longe de uma crítica a Rawls.
Mas o próximo passo será permitir que
você veja como esta noção
de justiça na propriedade
funciona no modelo de Nozick.
O que Nozick continua dizendo
é que as propriedades de uma
pessoa são justas
se ela tem direito às mesmas
pelos princípios da justiça
na aquisição e transferência ou
em situações imperfeitas
pelo princípio da retificação.
Ou seja, é uma condição
necessária na justiça da
propriedade
que elas sejam adquiridas por
uma dessas 2 etapas.
Mas também é uma
condição suficiente.
Se as propriedades da pessoa são
justas, então não há mais
questionamentos a serem feitos sobre a
agregação de propriedades.
Se as propriedades da
pessoa são justas,
então a distribuição das
propriedades é justa.
Portanto, vamos ver quando chegarmos
à justiça na transferência
como é que esta noção, tanto de
pegar propriedades históricas
como uma determinação
relevante de justiça
quanto de pegar a caracterização
indutiva da propriedade
como necessária e suficiente para a
justiça na propriedade...
como essas 2 coisas fornecem a
Nozick o estímulo para criticar
a perspectiva de que todos vocês, por
trás do véu da ignorância
– ou a maioria de vocês, por trás
do véu da ignorância –
parecem pensar que foi
o que a justiça determinou.
Ou seja, Nozick assume um
argumento a partir desse quadro
muito simples que, desde o
seu ponto de vista,
qualquer tipo de redistribuição
centralizada de recursos é ilegítima.
Então, vocês se lembram,
com o intuito de avaliar a
definição indutiva de Nozick,
precisamos saber o que ele pensa
que a justiça na aquisição envolve.
E o que ele pensa que a justiça
na transferência envolve.
Portanto, a discussão sobre a
justiça na aquisição
é uma parte bastante
complicada do texto
que vocês tinham para a aula de hoje.
Nozick apela para o trabalho do
filósofo John Locke,
Second Treatise on Government
[Segundo tratado sobre o Governo],
que inicia a discussão sobre
propriedade assim...
Locke escreve: "Ainda que a Terra e
todas as criaturas inferiores
pertençam em comum a todos os homens,
cada um guarda a propriedade de
sua própria pessoa;
sobre esta ninguém tem
qualquer direito,
exceto ela.
Podemos dizer que o trabalho de seu
corpo e a obra produzida
por suas mãos são propriedade sua".
Assim, na imagem do estado
de natureza de Locke
há um mundo lá fora, sem dono.
Estamos deixando de lado um
conjunto de preocupações
sobre esta imagem – que a Terra e
todas as criaturas inferiores
pertençam em qualquer sentido de
princípios aos seres humanos –,
analisando o que abrange o
argumento de Locke
para a justiça na
cláusula de aquisição.
Assim, para Locke, o mundo
dos objetos lá fora
não pertence a ninguém.
Mas o que cada pessoa tem
é o direito ao seu próprio
corpo e, em particular,
a posse, os direitos de
propriedade sobre o seu trabalho.
Locke afirma: "Sempre que ele
tira um objeto do estado
em que a natureza o colocou e deixou,
mistura nisso o seu trabalho e
a isso acrescenta algo
que lhe pertence, por isso o
tornando sua propriedade".
Concluindo: "Ao remover este
objeto do estado comum
em que a natureza o colocou, através
do seu trabalho adiciona-lhe
algo que excluiu o direito
comum dos outros homens.
Sendo este trabalho uma propriedade
inquestionável do trabalhador,
nenhum homem, exceto ele, pode ter o
direito ao que o trabalho
lhe acrescentou, pelo menos
quando o que resta
é suficiente aos outros, em
quantidade e em qualidade".
Então Nozick tira 2 coisas
dessa conclusão de Locke.
A 1ª coisa absorvida é a ideia de
que a justiça na aquisição
envolve um certo tipo de mistura do
que é a posse própria,
o trabalho próprio, com algo que
não tem dono prévio...
a propriedade potencial no
estado de natureza.
E, apesar disso, Nozick tem
todos os tipos de críticas
sobre a falta de clareza
dessa caracterização.
Ele comenta, por exemplo: "Se eu
for para Marte e limpar
uma parte do planeta, eu posso
reclamar essa parte para mim?
Eu posso reclamar todo o
planeta para mim?
Eu posso reclamar todos os planetas que
se encontram na sua órbita?".
Ele também pergunta por que a
mistura de um trabalho com algo
deveria levar à posse do objeto,
em vez da perda do próprio trabalho.
Mas, em última análise, ele está
disposto a aceitar que algo parecido
à imagem de Locke será a base da
justiça na aquisição.
O que o preocupa, e o que ele
dedica a maior parte
do trecho lido por vocês,
é o que ele chama
de condição lockeana, a ideia de que,
para que a aquisição seja legítima,
é necessário que tenha
deixado o suficiente
e tão bom em comum para os outros.
Quer essa cláusula seja
frequentemente violada.
Porque se essa cláusula for
frequentemente violada,
então a justiça na aquisição
não seria simples e direta
da maneira que Nozick deseja.
Assim, a estrutura básica do
argumento que vocês leram...
e eu vou apresentar mais
detalhes dela em 1 minuto...
a estrutura básica do argumento
no contexto da discussão de Nozick
sobre Locke é a seguinte:
Locke tem uma imagem razoável
do que a aquisição da
propriedade envolve.
Nós precisamos aparar as suas arestas,
mas eu não vou me preocupar
com isso, diz Nozick.
O que eu me preocupo é se essa
noção de que tenha
"deixado o suficiente e tão bom
em comum para os outros"
vai minar todo o modelo de Locke.
Então, qual é a ideia?
Vamos supor que nós 4
encontramos um pasto com vacas
previamente não reclamadas.
E 1 de nós reivindica 4 vacas.
E, em seguida, outro de nós
reivindica 6 vacas e um 3º
reivindica as 6 vacas restantes.
Será que a cláusula
lockeana foi violada?
A 1ª preocupação de Nozick,
a preocupação da descompressão,
é que talvez não seja só
o personagem azul
– que tomou as últimas 6 vacas –
quem violou a cláusula lockeana.
Talvez o personagem amarelo, ao
limitar o personagem azul,
a tenha violado e o personagem vermelho,
ao limitar o personagem amarelo,
limitando o personagem azul,
de alguma forma violou a
cláusula lockeana.
Nozick diz que não.
O fato de que as atividades do
personagem vermelho
limitaram as atividades do
personagem amarelo,
se considerarmos as atividades
do personagem azul,
não é suficiente para renderem
ao vermelho ou amarelo
a violação da cláusula lockeana.
Então, esse é o 1º passo.
Mas ainda podemos questionar
se o personagem azul
violou a cláusula lockeana.
Afinal, como ele poderia ter deixado
tanto e tão bom para o nosso 4º
personagem – o rosa aqui –
se o rosa não está em posição
de obter nenhuma vaca?
A resposta de Nozick é que ao
assumir a posse dos objetos
e misturar o trabalho com eles,
normalmente o que o sujeito faz
é aumentar o valor desses
objetos para todos.
Portanto, o vermelho, com
as suas 4 vacas,
pode produzir um galão de leite.
O amarelo pode produzir 2 e o
azul pode produzir 3.
Como consequência, o rosa
– embora ele não tenha acesso
às vacas – está melhor.
E, segundo Nozick, a cláusula
lockeana não foi violada.
O que Nozick faz, em especial, é
perguntar se a situação
das pessoas que são
incapazes de se apropriar
– não havendo mais objetos
acessíveis e sem dono –
é agravada por um sistema
de apropriação
e permissão da propriedade privada?
E a resposta dele é um não rotundo.
Exatamente pelo mesmo motivo
que já estamos familiarizados em
nosso caso de Hobbes...
a ideia de que existe uma
espécie de contrato social
que entra em ação permitindo
que todos se beneficiem.
E também porque Nozick acredita
firmemente que a propriedade
individual traz consigo um tipo
particular de eficiência.
Assim, a preocupação de Nozick
era: a cláusula lockeana
vai derrubar a minha teoria de tal
modo que eu não consiga obter
a cláusula base do meu
argumento indutivo?
A conclusão de Nozick é que a
apropriação da propriedade privada
satisfaz a intenção por
trás da cláusula do
"suficiente e tão bom" deixado.
Mas ele tem o cuidado de salientar
que isso não se baseia no
raciocínio utilitarista.
Não está baseado numa justificação
utilitarista para a propriedade.
Nozick, como Rawls, se preocupa com a
articulação de uma teoria
baseada nos direitos.
E, também como Rawls,
não permite as negociações dos
direitos por utilidades.
Portanto, o argumento sobre a
aquisição originária da propriedade
é a seguinte.
Nozick afirma: eu tenho o
direito de fazer tudo
o que não prejudique os outros
e o direito de fazer apenas o que
não prejudique os outros.
Os meus direitos começam e terminam
nas restrições e permissões
deles em consideração aos
danos causados aos outros.
Violar a cláusula lockeana, se
eu consegui fazer isso,
seria deixar os outros em
pior situação
do que teria sido de outra forma e,
consequentemente, prejudicá-los.
Como consequência, diz Nozick,
eu não tenho o direito de
violar a cláusula lockeana.
Se a minha aquisição originária da
propriedade não deixa tanto
e tão bom para os outros, então a
minha aquisição originária
não foi uma instância de
apropriação justa.
Mas, segundo Nozick, exceto
em casos muito raros
– de condições de catástrofe ou
limitações deserto-ilha –
a aquisição de propriedade não
viola a cláusula lockeana
ou prejudica os outros.
E o argumento para esta subcláusula,
este subargumento, está
baseado na utilidade.
Está baseado na utilidade
cuja a premissa é que,
exceto em casos raros,
adquirir a propriedade
não viola a cláusula lockeana.
Mas o argumento fundamental, eu
tenho o direito de fazer tudo
e tão-somente o que não
prejudique os outros.
Exceto em casos muito raros, a
aquisição de bens
não viola a cláusula lockeana
e prejudica os outros.
Aquele 1, mais 4, é
suficiente para concluir que,
exceto em casos muito raros,
eu tenho o direito de
adquirir uma propriedade.
Isto é, por meio da
exposição, o que eu entendo
ter sido uma parte bastante
difícil do texto atribuído.
Portanto, vamos passar agora a um
segmento mais fácil do texto.
Como observamos, Nozick fornece a
sua defesa da cláusula base
apelando para a noção de
aquisição originária da
propriedade
de Locke e a defende da
objeção potencial
– a objeção da
cláusula lockeana –
fornecendo um sentido mais
claro do que isso abrange.
Em muitos aspectos, a parte
mais famosa do texto
defende a cláusula de
indução de Nozick.
Portanto, em defesa da
cláusula de indução
– que, lembrem-se, diz
que se P adquire H
em conformidade com o princípio da
justiça na transferência,
de alguém que já tinha direito,
esse P tem o direito de H –,
Nozick está preocupado com o que a
justiça na transferência abrange.
Ele começa por distinguir algo que
já deve ser familiar a vocês
a partir da leitura de Mill e de Kant
no início deste semestre.
Ele faz uma distinção entre os
princípios que são históricos
– que dizer se uma
distribuição é justa
depende do surgimento dela.
Ou seja, se estamos preocupados
com o quando, estamos
preocupados com a justiça numa
questão de processo.
E ele contrasta isso com
o que ele chama de princípios
do resultado final,
em que saber se uma
distribuição é justa
depende de como as coisas
são distribuídas.
Vocês se lembram que
quando líamos Kant
e tentávamos determinar se uma
ação contava como moral
ou moralmente louvável,
Kant estava preocupado
com o processo pelo qual a
ação foi realizada.
Mill, ao contrário, estava
preocupado com o resultado.
Nozick continua, nas passagens
iniciais do Capítulo 7,
fornecendo uma defesa dos princípios
históricos e argumentando
que uma consequência será
que nunca podemos julgar a
justiça de uma sociedade
analisando como os seus bens
são distribuídos.
Ele destaca que tem sido típico
na articulação das teorias
da justiça alegar
que a sociedade é justa se os
bens são distribuídos
de acordo com algum tipo de critério
independentemente especificável.
Por exemplo, distribuir bens
de acordo com o mérito moral
de quem os recebe,
de acordo com a inteligência
de acordo com o esforço dos indivíduos
ou de acordo com a necessidade deles
pelos objetos distribuídos.
Nozick assinala que as pessoas querem
que a sociedade pareça justa.
E elas também querem que a
sociedade seja justa.
Mas ao pedir que a
sociedade analise o justo,
Nozick pensa que se comete um
erro ao tomar como padrão
uma forma de determinar o
resultado legítimo.
Será que o olhar da
justiça, indaga Nozick,
deve residir num padrão resultante
de que podemos especificar
de forma independente e
com antecedência
em vez dos princípios
subjacentes geradores?
E pensar sobre isso nos ajuda a
uma distinção de 3 vias
que John Rawls faz no contexto de
Uma Teoria da Justiça.
Rawls distingue 3 tipos de
justiça processual.
O 1º é uma noção do que ele chama de
justiça processual perfeita.
É um caso onde temos um
critério independente
para o que será o resultado
correto de nosso ato
e um procedimento certo para nos
fornecer esse resultado.
Por exemplo, se eu estou
tentando dividir um bolo,
e todos nós queremos uma fatia,
existe um critério independente do
processo que se tem de seguir.
Ou seja, cada um de nós
recebe uma fatia exatamente
do mesmo tamanho.
E há um procedimento certo para se
chegar a esse resultado.
O que eu faço é permitir
que uma pessoa corte
e que ela escolha a sua
fatia por último.
Enquanto ela estiver na posição de
fazer os cortes precisos,
o resultado deste
procedimento sempre nos
dará
o que nós especificamos de
forma independente
como o resultado buscado.
Queremos fatias iguais, temos um
critério independente
para o resultado correto e temos
um procedimento exato.
Aquele que corta escolhe por último.
Em contrapartida, na maioria dos casos,
nós nos encontramos numa situação
em que a nossa única opção
é o que Rawls chama de justiça
processual imperfeita.
Onde temos um critério independente
para o resultado correto, mas o
procedimento que temos
para alcançar tal
resultado é imperfeito.
Por exemplo, no sistema judicial,
temos um objetivo de condenar
todos e tão-somente aqueles que
são culpados de um crime.
Nós temos um sentido claro
de qual é o resultado correto.
Mas embora tenhamos um
procedimento que provavelmente
faça um bom negócio, melhor
que o acaso, é inegável
que em algumas ocasiões os
culpados acabam em liberdade.
E, da mesma forma,
é inegável que de vez em quando
inocentes são condenados.
O 3º tipo de justiça processual
é o que Rawls chama de justiça
puramente processual.
É um caso de não ter
nenhuma forma independente
para especificar o resultado.
O que nós fazemos é
adotar um procedimento
pelo qual vamos realizar em tempo real
uma espécie de distribuição.
E o resultado desse procedimento,
seja qual for a
distribuição, é justo.
Os jogos de azar têm essa estrutura.
Existe uma regra.
Nós colocamos o nosso dinheiro e,
em seguida, tiramos a nossa sorte.
E seja qual for a distribuição de
resultados proveniente disso é legítima.
A alegação de Nozick é que a
distribuição de bens numa sociedade
deve ser entendida como submetida
não a algum tipo de justiça
processual perfeita ou imperfeita.
Ou seja, sem critério independente
de como é que os bens devem ser
distribuídos entre as pessoas.
Pelo contrário, é
simplesmente uma questão
de viver historicamente através de um
processo pelo qual as coisas
são necessárias de forma justa e
transferidas de forma justa,
vendo como é que as
coisas se distribuem.
Assim, em contraste com algum
tipo de imagem padrão,
Marx tem esta ideia "de cada qual,
segundo sua capacidade;
a cada qual, segundo suas necessidades".
É uma ideia de que não existe
um critério independente
de como as coisas devem
ser distribuídas.
Nozick proporciona, em contraste,
esta articulação bastante
complicada: "De cada um segundo
o que ele resolve fazer
e o que os outros resolvem
fazer por ele."
Isto é, desde que o
processo seja justo,
as coisas que se distribuem
vão acabar sendo justas.
E isso dá origem ao famoso
argumento de Nozick
de que a liberdade perturba os padrões.
Então Nozick nos pede para
imaginar um mundo
em que todos os nossos amigos, por
trás do véu da ignorância,
recebem uma parcela igual do
que foi dada a eles
na distribuição justa.
Cada um deles termina
com um cofrinho de
tamanho considerável.
Mas todos eles, relata Nozick,
são fãs de basquete
e optam por pegar 1/4 do dinheiro
e depositá-lo na conta
bancária de Wilt Chamberlain.
E o mesmo ocorre com os amigos deles,
com os amigos dos amigos
deles e por aí vai...
até que, como resultado de uma
transferência legítima permitida,
Wilt Chamberlain passa a
ter tanto dinheiro
que o cofrinho dele não aguenta.
Ele está extraordinariamente rico.
Nozick aponta que o exemplo Wilt
Chamberlain tem 2 implicações.
A 1ª é uma implicação descritiva.
O ponto geral ilustrado pelo
exemplo Wilt Chamberlain
é que nenhum princípio de estado final
ou distributivo padronizado de
justiça pode ser continuamente
implementado sem interferência
contínua na vida das pessoas.
Qualquer padrão preferido
seria transformado
pelo princípio em outro não favorecido
– por pessoas trocando bens e
serviços com outras pessoas
ou dando a estas pessoas coisas a
que elas tinham direito
de acordo com o padrão
distributivo preferido.
A fim de manter o padrão,
teríamos ou que interferir
no processo de
transferência de
recursos
ou interferir de tal forma
para tomar de alguém
a sua pilha de dinheiro adquirida
legitimamente e redistribui-la.
A fim de manter o padrão, , diz
Nozick, teríamos ou que interferir
para impedir que as pessoas
transferissem recursos como quisessem
ou interferir para tomar de
algumas delas recursos
que outras decidiram
transferir para elas.
Portanto, essa é a implicação
descritiva do exemplo Wilt Chamberlain.
Há também uma implicação
normativa do mesmo exemplo.
Nozick diz para ver se D1, a
distribuição inicial
onde cada um dos personagens por
trás do véu da ignorância
tinha o cofrinho...
se D1 era uma distribuição justa.
E as pessoas voluntariamente
passaram-na de D1 para D2, aquela
em que Wilt Chamberlain acabou com um
grande quantia de dinheiro.
Ao transferir parte das parcelas
que haviam recebido sob D1, D2
não será também justa?
Se as pessoas tinham o direito
de usar os recursos
a que tinham direito sob D1, isso
não incluiria o direito
dá-los ou trocá-los com
Wilt Chamberlain?
Alguém poderia queixar-se disso
por razões de justiça?
Todas as outras pessoas, diz Nozick,
já possuíam a sua parcela
legítima sob D1
e depois que alguém transfere
algo para Wilt Chamberlain,
as suas parcelas não são alteradas.
Assim, a alegação descritiva
é que a liberdade vai,
inevitavelmente, perturbar os padrões.
E a alegação normativa é
que, fazendo isso,
não ocorreu nenhuma injustiça.
Eu vou fechar com 2 motivos
que nos faz pensar
que este argumento não funciona
tão claramente como Nozick acredita.
O 1º já foi visto por nós;
é que muitas situações têm a
estrutura do problema dos comuns
do que se poderia tomar
consciência antecipadamente.
E nem sempre é o caso
de que as transações
individuais entre pares de
pessoas
não carreguem consigo
consequências de terceiras
partes.
O 2º é que, às vezes,
a distribuição de recursos de forma
desigual entre os indivíduos
produz violações dos tipos de
liberdades que Nozick visa defender.
Então vamos supor que temos
2 grupos de pessoas,
cada um possui quantias
semelhantes de dinheiro.
E eles enviam os filhos para a escola
e compartilham o mesmo
conjunto de professores.
Vamos supor que um desses grupos,
por meio da transferência
legítima de D1 para D2,
tenha uma quantia muito
maior de dinheiro
e crie uma outra escola,
enviando os seus filhos
a ela e contratando os professores
que eram os mais talentosos.
Pode ser o caso de que, como
consequência de as pessoas
terem se engajado num
comportamento que envolveu
uma série de transferências
independentemente legítimas,
a situação resultante impeça a
liberdade dessas crianças de
se tornarem cidadãos do tipo cujos
direitos Nozick deseja defender.
Bom, já são 11h20...
Vamos terminar por aqui a aula de hoje.
E na próxima aula acabamos com
a discussão de Nozick
sobre a justiça na propriedade
e pensamos sobre isso
no contexto de um trabalho da
psicologia social.